good morning it's awfully early to be
talking about dirty family secrets but
that is indeed why we're here on a
Sunday my name is Bill Buford
I am the new yorkers literary and
fiction editor and i welcome you to an
exceptional panel consisting of four
contributors to the magazine who have
written some of the most radical
adventurous surprising and successful
memoirs of our time in fact the very
variety of these four authors points to
the difficulty of the term memoir so to
to their backgrounds one began writing
at 65 another began writing probably
around the age of 25 one was an
established poet with two books already
to her credit a professor of literature
another was the successful novelist and
perhaps his case is the most surprising
there's generally view that
autobiography has taken the place of the
novel after all a great deal of fiction
is as we all know pretty
autobiographical you think of Saul
Bellow and his girlfriend's Philip Roth
and his girlfriends John Updike well you
get the idea I should speak
autobiographically as the fiction editor
of The New Yorker and I can admit there
are moments when you get a little too
intimate with your authors and you
discover mmm authors who will remain
nameless the moment that you know I
could still remember Richard Ford set
Noah my nameís for it was marnay masala
mr. Davis of Patmos speaking a moment
ago is an extremely accomplished
novelist perhaps the greatest sentence
writer I would vouch in the English
language why did he need to write a
memoir and maybe that's a crucial clue
the notion that the memoirs just a
substitute for the novel probably is an
L that accurate after all the memoir
especially the American memoir has been
around us for a long time and I'm not
just thinking of the memoirs of Lee
Iacocca and PT bottom which participate
in another American tradition what I
could describe as a sort of Sammy Davis
jr. Frank Sinatra theme I did it my way
Buster but that one that goes back all
the way to the origins of the United
States itself after all our founding
father Benjamin Franklin wrote his
autobiography there's Mark Twain's
musings the songs of Walt Whitman the
extraordinary autobiography of Henry
Adams as well as present-day
achievements like the wolf brothers
Jeffries Duke of deception and Toby's
this boy's life
even so there are some of central
features which unite this diverse panel
it is evident for instance that all of
them have a vested professional and
highly commercial interest in the repeal
of the laws of Prohibition if it had
been impossible for Muhammad dad to have
the occasional drink you know the
intermittent leader of vodka are several
Imperial gallons of deep dark Guinness
then damn there'd be a lot less to write
about equally and powerfully evident
that our writers needed to have really
really bad times in to write in order to
write good things about them there are
things so awful and I mean really really
really awful that they've got to be good
in preparing this morning's panel I kept
thinking of that East LA expression as
in yeah man it's bad like bad and all
the writers have had that kind of bad
experience so bad it's good it also
points to the power of the family
another feature uniting our four writers
and this puts me in mind of the great
poem by the English poet Philip Larkin
they [ __ ] you up your mum and dad they
don't mean to but they do but really as
all the writers who will agree Philip
Larkin got it wrong is also your uncle's
your aunt's your cousin's your cousin
cousins your in-laws in fact there are a
lot of people the fun matter this
morning is this will talk among
ourselves for a while I might brutally
and capriciously ask one of the authors
to read something and then at the end
I'm looking forward to some questions
from you so keep those in mind allow me
to introduce people who certainly don't
need introducing Frank McCourt who spent
most of his adult life up writing is on
my right who then at the age of 65
decided that it was time to get around
to this thing he kept putting off he is
of course the author of Angela's Ashes
and tis and of course the story of
Angela's Ashes is really bad
the poet Mary Karr - growing up in
hardscrabble swappi East Texas was the
mother had a mother who married more
than dated and boy did she marry
divorcing six times in marrying seven
times as written two extraordinary
autobiographies the liar's club largely
inspired by mom and cherry a frank
inspired account of a young woman's
sexuality the novelist and essayist
Martin Amos on my left my father who
really should have known better and the
extraordinary Dave Eggers a
heartbreaking genius who wrote a
heartbreaking work of staggering genius
and the editor of McSweeney's welcome
right let me begin with you why did it
take so long I'm the senior member here
I feel like renaming this panel Sunday
with striplings it took me so long
because I I didn't take the big the big
leap when I was in my early twenties
because I was afraid when I came to New
York to do anything daring like that
just gets secured get a little room in
East six days to make sure you have some
food some some some pocket money and try
to get laid from time to time by going
to Irish dance halls which was a waste
of time anyway so and I I didn't I was
even afraid to ask women to dance
because Irish women always say no that's
their to me anyway
I know they're worth the work there were
Buccaneers around me but I wasn't I was
shy and then then I was drafted into the
army sent to Germany for two years where
I trained dogs and that was that was
that was that was a pretty good training
for my future career as a teacher then I
then when I got out of the army I I want
to NYU because the GI Bill which is a
glorious piece of legislation so then I
was able to go to NYU and I decide the
only thing that I thought I was fit for
was teaching but I didn't know it I was
I was getting into the hardest thing a
human being could possibly do the
writers are always morning but have to
go to their desks in the morning
struggle what their deem is good try try
a hundred and sixty American teenagers
worrying about their pimples and zits
and everything else so I when you teach
five classes a day five days a week you
atom users are not flourishing in your
head you don't run
to write the novel or anything yet I
scribbled ice-covered the notebooks all
those years I scribbled and as the
mother my students would ask me about my
life and because I have a what they call
a bloke well you got a broad yeah I got
a pro so and then they worry they want
to know if I was from Scotland a person
like that and I would tell them I would
tell them some dole out some anecdotes
from my life because they wanted to know
about where I went to school what music
I like then things began to shape I
think they are there questions all even
apart from that I was scribbling in our
pocket I was discovering my material
while I was it while I was and I I just
go for the 30 years a teacher I used to
say I'll do it this summer but even in
July in August I had to go and get it a
job to supplement my princely teachers
income one so when did you realize that
your horrible experiences were so
entertaining
I think there was a moment one night at
a party in the Lower East Side where I
suddenly became a kind of that the
center of attention I became a kind of a
proletariat Oscar Wilde and I started
talking and people started listening to
my god but students of mine had been
listening but this is the first time a
group of adults began to listen and I
began to realize the power of my ability
to hold an audience or overdose but that
that has nothing discovering my metier
at this and discovering the value of my
childhood I didn't think anybody would
be interested in the usual miserable
child because when Angela's Ashes cannot
they would say Dickensian I'd be the
other adjectives you apply to Irish
writers as charming and lyrical or
always charming and they're very
charming as arrogant people
yeah well your house what's what's I
retired from teaching then I thought no
no is that no there's no avoiding and no
excuses anymore than I had to do it tape
your had similarly well actually I mean
no one there there's no similar
experience here among any of any of us I
think but I had a pretty hard scrabble
childhood and Lake Forest Illinois has
anyone and you're scrappy as a result
that what I can do yeah you didn't wait
until you were 65 you were actually
writing you were actually note-taking
while witnessing some pretty horrific
moments as your mother and then your
father died I was in college and I it
was the one creative writing course I
took I was writing about this stuff in
the at the exact same time I would go
home on the weekends and see some stuff
transcribe things and come back with his
tiny little stories about about it and
it was and I then I would read them to
the class so they would read them and
come back and just with these faces of
worry just like ash and you know like I
was a very scary guy at that point I had
no right to do it but I couldn't I
couldn't get around it it was all I
could think of and uh but when you went
to write the book did you go back to
those first vignettes and no no I didn't
I I've been writing in a journal since I
was about 12 and I didn't use any of it
until afterward I wrote the whole thing
out and I went back and just and
double-checked things but that was about
it
I couldn't have a hard time going back
and reading that stuff or that book or
anything to do with it
how long did take you to write the book
when I got down to it about nine months
I had to do it quickly to to get it out
you describe at one point in the book if
you have trouble you've got your very
cheeky wonderful introduction which
takes a swipe at just about everything
mainly yourself over and over again
there's the great exchange with your
friend where you admit that
yeah you're writing a memoir because all
come on
a memoir dude that guy wasn't my friend
and you say it a helpful tip to the
reader like just pretend it's fiction
yeah why didn't you write fiction uh why
why not call it fiction I mean do you do
you do these things all these
conversations they really took place is
it not made up is it not on some level I
mean I call it a reconstructed I think
you know generally what happened and
then to actually have a dialogue you
have to you just know what you'll
remember exactly what anyone said Anton
and because I was trained as a
journalist for the most part and so I
felt horrible guilt about trying to put
any of those things back together with
and and then actually put them between
quote marks and not you know between
brackets and with ellipses everywhere
and like we were taught to do and so uh
so I that's what a lot of that preface
is about my guilt about putting it all
back together and calling it nonfiction
calling it the the whole truth even when
I know that you had to do so much
fudging and so much helping to make it
uh make sense so I don't know Mary you
actually began a liar's club as a novel
I did and unfortunately I mean I think
the novel is just a much more
challenging art I the memoirs a is a is
a sort of Outsiders art it's a kind of
boneheads art it's it's necessarily it's
episodic and people either are compelled
enough by the voice to continue reading
or not but I think a novelist is an art
form there were you know has natural
structure beyond you know it was junior
year then it was senior year so having
to come up with
having to come up with all of with that
actual structure it sort of thwarted me
so and I've always been a fan of the
memoir I'd always loved memoirs and read
them ardently starting with st.
Augustine and for working my way down or
up as it were and in Cherry though the
effects in some ways are even more
literary there's a great part of the
book which is written in the second
person a great part of it's written in
the first person you're using a lot of
you know in some ways the material is
less ostensibly dramatic and it's it's
it's more subtle it's about the
sexuality of it sort of the coming
sexuality of a of a young woman more the
material of fiction well I mean I think
it's L it's historically been the
material fiction I think women memoirs
hit these ages and just pole vault right
past him you know partly because yeah I
mean I think it's less dramatic than you
to kiss John Cleary but I mean I've been
walking up and down the street in front
of John Cleary's house with I love John
clearly written on my shirt for five
years before I finally cornered him in
my garage so that was a dramatic moment
for me there was a lot of drama there I
mean nobody was armed - the way they the
way my family was but I mean hat I think
had I been able to write it as a novel
but I think it's also psychological I
think as a novel when I tried to write
as a novel the character who was me was
beautiful and Noble my sand knew
calculus and volunteered at the nursing
home
and I found it as a real opportunity I
think to correct history rather than to
and I think a real novelist in some ways
is able to tell the truth more in a
novel than he or she would be in that
form a novelist can tell the truth right
do you know what I mean
you've written an autobiography called
the liar's club and you bought it so did
a couple other people but as for writing
it in the second person I mean I think
there is I've never got a hitch junior
high and there's that sense particularly
if you ingest enough pharmaceuticals of
being estranged from yourself or set off
from yourself
and I actually had tried writing it in
the third person but I sounded like that
you know that wrestler the rock you know
he says the rock is the who talks about
himself in the third person the most
electrifying personality sports
entertainment tonight and I thought I
can't do this I'm gonna sound like the
rock
so can I been able had I not had that
nagging wrestler voice in the back of my
mind I would have written it in third
person Martin of all people who didn't
need to write a memoir you know it
seemed to be that person after all you
can do all of this in fiction you're a
great fiction writer why did you have to
go instead of there at all well two or
three reasons though but I I always
thought I'd have a pro bono duty to
write about my father because it's it's
so far true that that there haven't been
any father-son or parent-child writing
teams I mean usually what happens with
with these sort of Martin's father for
anybody who's just arrived from an outer
articles Kingsley Amis
a novelist what it usually happens with
this sort of David Updike's and and so
on is that they write and indeed the
Auburn over more is that they write for
a bit then they that's it they stop
because the point is being proved for
them I think it must be that they've
they've emulated the father and can now
relax but it wasn't like that with me I
mean I I was news long haul that I was
gonna be a writer all my life and it
wasn't to prove a point and it wasn't to
impress my dad anyway you know I did go
on so since we were this unique case I
was new I have to write about it and
when my father died there after a year
or two I thought this is the right time
another much weirder reason for writing
it was that um was something i I read
about me in the newspapers which
completely stunned me it was a it was a
piece saying that um two things that
emerged in my life and of course were
the made public of once but was that one
my cousin had been murdered by the the
most prolific serial murderer in English
history until recently Fred West and
this page had been unknown for twenty
years and then it emerged that this is
what happened to her and also I had a
daughter who only made herself known to
me when she was 19 these things all
happened at the same time and energy but
this piece in the newspaper written by a
novelist said that I've been writing
about this all along and but all my
books have these missing children in
them usually missing girls and and
fugitive fathers and you know
undisclosed parent-child relationships
and you know chests and talks about the
bitter criticism you'll read once in
your life that makes you jump out of
your boots and this had that effect on
me and I felt dusted really as a
novelist but you know there don't seem
to be completely true you know and so
obvious shaming me obvious so I thought
I I don't want to write fiction for a
bit and that was the other interpretive
thing of course when you write
nonfiction you have the problem that
it's unless you're writing something
called the liar's club
that's meant to be true just excuse me
I'm sure it's all true and and unless
you're Dave have yours and admit that
you're changing the names on the whole
and you're not changing many names I
mean not on the whole you you're
accountable to reality and you're
writing about the heart of all the
stories here are family stories and
you're writing about very intimate
people well remember that it brought
said when a writer is is born into a
family that's the end of that family
so it hasn't been the end of mine but
it's true I mean you immediately there's
there's something fairly
self-destructive in marrying a writer
yeah are having a writer yeah what you'd
like you'd like to be accountable to
reality but you can't they won't let you
the lawyers won't let you there are
things I wanted to write in the second
book tears and I spent six and a half
hours with the lawyers of Scrivener and
had to change names and it had to modify
situations the slightest whiff of
unethical behavior something it had to
be changed slightly so can you it
doesn't know how what you did you could
have well I give you one one small
example the major thing was my I wanted
to write about my first marriage and I
just I I couldn't I couldn't write what
they were really the way it was and
maybe this will get back to her she
lives in Brooklyn and you can tell it
but I want to throw out what that
marries what that marriage was really
like and I'm not taking I'm not blaming
her I just wanted to write the reality
of it because I was no angel either but
I couldn't so I eventually my
description of her made her look like a
cross between Mother Teresa and Madonna
said that I I didn't tell the truth I
didn't God couldn't tell the truth of
why the marry deteriorate and that
things that help to my daughter and so
on so because then I realized this weed
is no free expression you get involved
in lawsuits you you you've gone through
a minefield where you talk about things
like this so it's another house to make
her into a novelist that's it that's
what I'm doing
that's what I have to do and I remember
you said in an interview a minute and I
found this quite surprising but now it
makes sense is that your next book was
going to be fiction because you felt you
could write more in fiction than you
couldn't yeah it's uptight what James
Joyce shoots it's all about getting even
but I are the Kennedys just talk about
getting even - don't get mad get even
but I'm not mad I don't I don't
particularly want to get even a each to
tell a story is greater than any strong
emotion like that to tell to tell the
stories so now I I have to write a novel
because if I would if I were to write a
third memoir the one I want about the
years of teaching and like my room my
relationships with women and my daughter
and the goddamn Grateful Dead and and
and Jerry Garcia I couldn't die because
I can't write about that because my
daughter was upset over a piece that I
wrote in Rolling Stone about her and are
following that Jerry Garcia are on the
contrary
she was mad so I had to modify it
somehow so at this this is this is what
you're faced with there's really no free
expression I've always wondered
am i right thinking that by the time he
wrote Angela's Ashes your father and
your mother had died yep and is it
possible that actually the book became
possible because they died yeah well I
couldn't have my father wouldn't have K
didn't care what anybody did about
anything but my mother would have been
very upset over Angela's Ashes because
she's like many I suppose your and many
parents of her generation or even in my
generation you you you didn't want to
spill the beans you put on a good face
you didn't you didn't you always kept a
good face and she would have been
ashamed that's the thing because I
support it doesn't matter with your rich
poor or middle class you want to keep
the good face and you don't want to
spill the family secrets and the N in
her case I was vilified in Ireland over
the over my mother's write about my
mother's little sexual caper with her
cousin which she had to do to keep a
roof over our heads they missed the
point there but they said they said
you've shamed your mother you've shamed
the city of Limerick and you shame I'll
and I really don't give a [ __ ] about the
city of Limerick Ireland
but I did I did wrestle with that that
episode where I had to deal with my
mother and and and her cousin Mary we're
certain with death that liberating for
you in the same way no I mean my father
had been dead for a long time and my
mother was a painter and I think as a
portrait painter always had a sense of
you know what an artist brought to the
enterprise also in my family it's to
make a living doing anything that
doesn't involve walking between a pair
of plow handles looking up a Mules ass
I think the prospect of it was thrilling
I think to my Esav as a family as a
point of family honor I mean I
appreciate that I think my mother and
sister both but also I mean I think not
I think none of us I've been writing
poetry for 20 years so nobody really
expected anyone to read this and the
fact that did i cudgelled some poor
idiot publisher into giving me money for
I just for my mother saying and they
won't take the money back even if the
book doesn't sell now ma'am that's my
money well Kumud just get it off your
chest
so I mean we got a little ambushed you
know you buy actually selling books I
mean I think they did as well but no I
didn't have that I mean again I think
having the financial flamethrower on the
family backside is a great motivating
factor Dave how did how did them thank
you
how did members of your have you written
a very very intimate account of your
family how did the other members of your
family respond to the book it was a a
collaborative effort I mean everybody
had to weigh in way before hand I mean I
I said the book in manuscript form and
then even before that too you know
Toph and Bill and Beth our best diaries
were really important to me because she
was keeping track of things I was little
even better than I was at the time of
everything and she was home a whole year
while I was at college she was taking
care of everybody and so everybody was
was aware of everything way way away
beforehand I mean it was the extended
members of the family here and there
that I had forgotten or hadn't gotten a
chance to show it to or sometimes
expressed surprise but everybody was
really supportive I tried to show it to
almost everybody in the book except for
my old landlord Roger who uh he was the
one guy that I got even
it was really funny I meet people in it
when I'm in San Francisco I meet people
who have this guy as a landlord and like
yeah
so I didn't feel bad about that but
otherwise that's the man this is I have
the same problem as Frank I don't know
if I could ever read nonfiction in any
way shape or form again having even-even
profile of somebody like in a magazine
article or anything like that which I
used to do I have the responsibility is
so great and and you hear from people
and I change so many lives in the paper
back because I felt even more guilt
about things than did I really represent
that perfectly right that it's only
fiction from now on and fiction about
dogs and stuff about it
make it really easy Dave could you read
us up a page dude I could read it sort
of an applicable uh-huh passage I guess
oh this isn't a a this in the middle of
the book is a long extended a sort of
interview when I was kind of applying to
be on the real world MTV show and this
is sort of fudged but it was a way of
putting a bunch of episodes in one place
that I was too clumsy to work in and
some sort of more elegant way so this is
a in the middle of that I'm talking to
the interviewer
besides these things aren't even mine
this is talking about how can you how
could I be telling her all these
personal things if during the interview
these things aren't even mine none of
this is mine my father is not mine
not in that way his death and what he's
done or not mine
nor am i upbringing normal nor its
tragedies how can these things be mine
holding me responsible for keeping
hidden this information is ridiculous I
was born into a town and a family in the
town and my family happened to me I
owned none none of it it is everyone's
it is shareware I like it I like having
part of it I would kill her die to
protect those who are part of it but I
do not claim exclusivity have it take it
from me do with it what you will make it
useful this is like making electricity
from dirt it's almost too good to
believe to be believed that we can make
beauty from this stuff check it gone it
puts me in mind of one other thing about
the book which is them you describe it's
a complicated thing having a personal
tragedy that other people don't have in
one way it makes you unique I mean one
way it's terrible very very true I mean
fundamentally it's terrible you've lost
people close to you but another way it
almost becomes attractive and you
described in the book how it can be
attractive how it is a way of getting
pity or funds or scholarships or getting
laid or it is the book also doing that
sure see if the old financial
flamethrower there yeah well it's you
know it's a blessing and a curse you get
a lot of a lot of good things and a lot
of horrible things you know how that is
everybody goes through that you feel
like when you've written something like
that you've put it all on the table
you've you've specially in my case
you've you've defended yourself and
criticized yourself thoroughly and you
know ripped yourself apart already and
you figure well I've done it already no
one else will ever look could could at
whatever then one will touch me after
this you know like they'll feel too bad
about getting getting in and twisting
the nice Oh
yes it took a little while but it came
about but yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't do
it differently I had to do it over I
wouldn't recommend it to anybody doing
it but you sort of have to do it I
couldn't couldn't see past it and I knew
I knew I basically knew what was gonna
happen but it and and and unfortunately
it did all the good naved but it's been
it's been it's been great overall
there's a quote which I thought I just
put out here on the table from William
gas in complaining that literature has
been taken over by narcissists
William gas of course not being a
narcissist those a few people who've
read them the quote going look ma I'm
breathing see me take my initial toddy
use the potty scratch my sister wins
spin the bottle gee whiz my first
adultery what a guy I mean all of you
have made yourself your very exposed
your very vulnerable Martin in Britain
which people here may not entirely
appreciate it's a small country and
literary writers get much more attention
than here there's a National Press which
is always feeding on itself and most of
it is actually written by quite literate
people so the writer is actually sort of
a a subject of much much more attention
than in America where thankfully we've
got movie stars
this must have been a very vulnerable
act for you putting all that out there
why why what was already out there so it
was just the official version no it's
true what you say and in England there
is this very corrosive atmosphere to do
I think with the fact that you know if
you write about a filmmaker you don't
make a film about it if you assess a
musician you don't get out your banjo
and sing a song about him
etc but if you write about a writer than
you write about him in a prose narrative
so the they're in the same business as
you and don't tell me that their their
ambition when they started out was to
write profiles of writers what they
wanted to be was willis have profiles
written about them they wanted to have
you yeah oh yeah or the equivalent um
the why this isn't the case in America
as mysterious because you think
Hollywood just takes up the slack in
England there's so many newspapers there
certainly are five quality dailies
so-called etc they run out of you know
wife-beating footballers and
transvestite crooners and they reduced
to writing about knowledge
it's funny I love what you said it's
sort of like wanting to be a great lover
and winding up a gynecologist but you
also said you also said Martin something
interesting to me the other night and I
hope I'm not betraying a confidence to
repeat it but then you said that you
think it it humanized you in a way
because I do think I mean I've spent a
lot of time in the UK and I'd seen
unbelievably brutal treatment of you at
the hands of the so-called journalist
and you think in some ways it was almost
mitigated or did it make it worse
it made it better um probably because
you know when you write a memoir you
could have joined the human race really
because you show you suffer and that you
know the universal ills and uh you know
you don't escape them
whereas you can come on very glacial as
a novelist you can't do that as a member
of what was the response of family
members to your book universally fine
except for one novel with one cousin for
a week but I very much
I very much set up not offend anyone and
to give them to betray everyone in the
best possible life and and you find out
actually you know how [ __ ] up you are
when you write a memoir because you know
if you when I sat down I thought oh I'll
get my own back on etc etc but the
battle evaporates if you're basically
okay then that'll seems you know more
more relevant and incidental and you
don't pay off there any any scores you
don't settle grudges because that's not
what comes to the surface in in my case
and you know I think a memoir would be
deformed by by too much its core sadly
kiri dissipate yeah
and this comes just after a bit in one
of my father's novels the old devil's
when this a Welsh guide these - oh well
Kai's tell an American to [ __ ] off and
as they get into the car one of them
says anxiously they do say [ __ ] off in
America today the other one says I'm
sure they understand it
my father and I often had occasion to
agree that [ __ ] off was very funny one
naturally admired its brutality in
brevity but it's also terribly good but
the best [ __ ] off of all time had dad at
the receiving end of it or at least he
stage managed it so one afternoon in
Hampstead he came in through the front
front door after posting a letter
laughing quietly and richly to himself I
said what was so funny he said I saw a
bloody fool of a dog just now it was a
genuine summer's day concerted and
cloudless on his walk to the left box my
father had passed a full-grown Alsatian
or German Shepherd as you'd say
apparently asleep on the boiling breast
of a parked car my father looked
interestedly at the dog and the dog
roused itself and stared back as if to
say I'm lying on this car all right
on his walk on his walk back from the
letterbox my father looked at the dog
again and the dog stared back adding it
may be hot but I'm still lying on this
car but before opening the garden door
he turned for final grants what did I do
what what did it do I urged him because
he was laughing quietly enrich litter
and stuff it lifted its head from its
paws and straighten its neck and went
Kingsley did one of two things either he
made the bark sound exactly like [ __ ]
off or he made [ __ ] off sound exactly
like the park
another thing which I noticed runs
between actually all the books is that
there's sort of your books are like the
sort of child memos or there are the
moments when childhood ends I mean with
the obvious way to describe it I suppose
would be a loss of innocence and that
seems to be the engine especially in in
your books Mary especially the liar's
club I think you know I think I've read
memoirs again sort of ardently and as a
student of them I felt I feel for a long
time and I think any memoir that doesn't
have the person writing it as an
antagonist is is a mistaken form I mean
I'm always amazed when people undertake
memoirs as these acts of history as if
they're gonna render some objective
truth why would you describe the liar's
club once I think is not an active
history but an active memory right right
I mean you know allegedly you're if
you're writing a memoir what the reader
would get from you that they couldn't
get had you lived your life with a video
camera strapped to your head is your
take on things is how you felt as some
subject is subjective musing and worry
and concern and so I feel like I don't
know I mean I feel like if they're I
think in all of these books we're all
again as as annoyed and beleaguered by
aspects of our own characters certainly
I am even as even in a childhood memoir
so I think in that sense they you know
my book and all these books seem to
happen at a point when the character is
being developed or turned in a dramatic
way or have even yours Martin I think
which covers a broader broader period of
time you know through these key moments
when when the you know dramatic moments
when characters develop hopefully I mean
otherwise I mean I'm amazed that people
said and people have led much more
dramatic lives than mine and written
about them you know sex slavery you know
and not soul you know as you know as
many copies as I've sold not been on
bestseller Lester what
key moments for you I think my I mean
Lions Club opens with my mother's
psychotic episode I think it was a was
the one thing it was the one moment in
my life that I found very traumatic and
much more traumatic than many of the
other things that happened to me that I
think were adjudged grisly it's funny I
mean in cheery it's not so much actually
losing my cherry as it is discovering a
kind of passion and innocence and
falling in love with poetry I think in a
way was I think in some ways falling in
love with language was much more
critical yeah visionary sort of language
and sexuality are sort of two
discoveries at once right I think
they're related I think both those
things do you think that writers don't
in fact lose all their innocence that
you need you need a bit of innocence to
be a writer you copy to wised up it's I
think strongly distinguishes right
ethnicity well that's the
misunderstanding I had about that the
whole business all those years
as a high school teacher so and then
take they're going to work on the Staten
Island Ferry of the subways and reading
the tape and rebuttal it surprised when
as I saw but my particular when I was
writing I really didn't think about the
future of anything I was writing it I
thought dangerous ashes would seven
three four copies two middle-aged Irish
widows and I got back into obscurity but
then then I began to wonder about
critics and it all of us have had
experience with critics I began to
wonder about I was particularly I knew I
thought I was going to be mauled in
England but it wasn't it did the book
took off very slowly in England but I
knew they were worried for me in Dublin
and when you talk of you talk about a
claustrophobic society and they did they
were there while there are certain Irish
intellectuals who rose up in theory and
I'm still wondering and it delights me
that I irritated them so much because
they're all academics and I was what
rule did I break there was one rule
there are some rules that I broke
because unanimously I was attacked by
them and in initially you're you're you
you just want to like ask them to step
outside but after after that girl you
become cure so what is that what is it
that I what rule did I brought break so
that I can do it again one of them I
remember since it's a chance to name
names it was actually a friend of mine
Seamus Dean who is an academic what's
interesting about Seamus who wrote an
autobiographical novel and didn't win
the Booker Prize and it began his
autobiography and he could be completed
until his parents died and then he
published it as fiction so maybe his
grievance was that it was all about the
books chemo simultaneously and an Angela
buried shameless Dean and they made it
into a movie and everything and I met
Paul for many beautiful women
which is part of what you were talking
about a while about Dave of what the
stuff you have to do well I don't I
don't find it I don't find anything
negative about that it's it for me it's
a it's unlike the rest of this is very
very recent stuff from me and my I could
write a book about the events of the
last five years including what we're
talking about now they they they the
Roth of the Irish intellectuals and and
certain other people in Limerick
particularly where where I you know you
have to look over your shoulder walking
up the street but that that's and it's
all new obviously I was mauled on
television in one night in Dublin so and
all of this all of this is new to me
well they planted some guy in the
audience with a yellow jacket
he's uh he's from Limerick and he he he
he took on my destruction is his main
cause in life and he you know he thought
he said can you imagine this so he wants
to Angela's Ashes and found 170
inconsistencies it's only three hundred
and sixty pages long so in every other
page it was an inconsistency so Andy and
he's been obsessed with me for a year
but I think I know that I'm fading into
obscurity he has to do likewise but
unless I write a novel and he's in it
somewhere in the yard
in a yellow jacket you see the rest of
you you know you've been at this for
years and years and I emerge from high
school teaching and I'm an innocent you
talk about innocence man yeah you're in
the limelight
you know no you're just blinded you put
out the merry car in the garret really
nice shoes and then yet the other night
at a panel you said James McBride who
wrote the color of water James you know
James is a very cool character plays the
saxophone and everything and he said he
writes and he's very honest and and
writing is a new thing for him and he
said he writes from a from a pure place
and I believed it then miss Carson world
pure place I write for the money which
is [ __ ] because she what she does
write from it from the pure purse but
this is the bad girl so don't believe a
word you say she is a member of the
liar's club where he's just on these
hopping up and down on this Buford what
is it are you bill Tania not me no you
take I'll take you both just call a
literary debate Frank how about that an
intermission and read you're reading us
a page what this has to do with what I'm
saying about freedom of expression it
continues it we certainly didn't have it
in Ireland where every book of note was
banned everything and the Irish
censorship both still exist so it was
very hard to get a you couldn't get
Hemingway or anybody you could get many
Irish Edna O'Brien was banned and you're
Jake Joyce's Ulysses was banned because
it wasn't bad because nobody could read
it in the first
and this this has to do with the
librarian Limerick there was no
children's library so my mother would
send me to the library to borrow some
put two books she was at your lord at
two books every two weeks and if you
finish them you can't bring them back
before the end of the tour we so she
gave me a note to go to the library and
it's raining so hard one day mr. Riordan
the librarian says don't go often that
way you'll ruin the books you're
carrying sit down over there and behave
yourself you can read all about the
saints while you're waiting there are
four big books bottlers lives of the
saints I don't want to spend the rest of
my life reading about saints but when I
start reading I wish the rain would last
forever
whenever you see pictures of saints men
or women they're always looking up to
heaven whether a clouds filled with
little fat angels carrying flowers or
harps giving praise my uncle Paquita
says he can't think of a single saint in
heaven he'd want to sit down and have a
pint with the Saints in these books are
different there are stories about
virgins marked as virgin martyrs and
they're worse than any horror film at
the lyric cinema I have to look in the
dictionary to find out what a virgin is
I was 9 or 10 at the time I know the
mother of God is the Virgin Mary and
they call her that because she didn't
have a proper husband only poor old st.
Joseph in the lives of the saints the
Virgin's are always getting into trouble
and I don't know why the dictionary says
virgin woman usually a young woman who
is and remains in a state of inviolate
chastity now I have to look up in violet
and chaste evasion and all I can find
here is that in violent means not
violated and chastity means chase and
that means pure from unlawful sexual
intercourse now I have to look up
intercourse and that leads to copulation
the union of the sexes in the octave
generation and I don't know what that
means and I'm too weary going for one
more to another in this heavy dictionary
which leads me on a wild goose chase
from this word to that word and all
because the people who altered
dictionary don't want the likes of me to
know anything
that's the question of innocence I
thought for both Martin and Dave you
know a traditional narrative if the
traditional nerve has beginning middle
and end a traditional narrative is
actually Martin what you're as
untraditional and unconventional and as
radical as your writing often is you
know how to tell a story your novels are
often characterized by a very firm grasp
of the condition conventional narrative
both of you written extremely
unconventional books when you start to
write about your own lives Martin I'm
wondering how how would you describe the
form of experience well it's the the
most poetic of all autobiographies is is
the matter cough speak memory which
which isn't about the formation of the
man it's about the formation of the
talent and it deals with themes and
emblems and colors and I didn't want
onion be very pleased to write such a
book but I didn't want to do that but I
didn't I certainly didn't want to sit
down and write write I was you know I
was born on 25th of August 1949 hour
died with boredom after ten minutes if
I'd done it that way so I thought it's
got it's got to be fun for me so I just
sort of feel my way theoretically the
other thing is that if you don't do it
chronologically you can leave stuff out
otherwise it's full of holes if you
could do it chronologically you have to
deal with your marriage I didn't want to
write about my marriage except very
indirectly but it was it was all
instinctive I mean Eve even write
fiction is deeply instinctive that even
though even a memoir is is a very
instinctive is it's much more negative
than people think how is it different
from writing fiction how is that book
different for you well
it was it was I I could tell it was
different because my whole metabolism
changed it really did I was I'm not an
early riser but I was staying in bed
till one o'clock in the afternoon and
getting up very reluctantly at one
o'clock
not because I was exhausted so much as I
was just loving lying there you know I
was emotionally exhausted by it in a way
that you can't write fiction like that
you can't you can't let your emotions
well up that's the difference that
whether them are you know you're swamped
violently just you can't get out of the
way
Dave how would you describe the form of
your heartbreaking work I think
form and all would be an overstatement
well it's got form its rectangular yeah
yeah that much I knew how to do oh I
don't know I was the same way I had
never I had never finished writing us a
story even a three-page story in my life
that the story about the dog was the
first story I've ever actually finished
it's in net cranberries collection so I
had no experience with it at all I only
knew that I wanted it I knew that one
thing I couldn't do is a linear
narrative I knew that I was gonna be
really bad at that and so I just kept on
inventing gimmicks to keep myself
entertained the same way like I was
really at a standstill until at one
point and had nowhere to go and trying
to finish it or trying to make sense of
it and wondering if I should give it up
and then I thought of I came up with the
the idea of having Toph speak out of
character and sort of take the book
apart during a few of our conversations
and then the real world thing happened
and then that was a way to deal with
stuff deeper in the past and those sort
of the lack of a better word gimmicks
were the only things that kept me going
through it was
because otherwise you do have this this
problem and then that happened and this
happened that happened and I knew I
couldn't do that because it would would
have been a 1,300 pages I think just to
cover it to accurately cover a year or
something from like a journalistic
perspective stomach sounds I was always
trying to I don't know it doesn't make
any sense at all so a way of sorting out
the emphases really you telling that you
can't write your life as if every day
was you know have the same resonance and
value you just have to go from death to
death to death it's one way of
organizing one lively way of doing yeah
yeah you got really cheerful stuff in
your book frankly Mary could you read us
something from the laptop um this is um
after this psychotic episode of my
mother's they come and take her but what
we call capitulate away for being kept
allanne Novus which in the South covers
a wide territory pretty much anything
from nail-biting to psychosis without
real data on mothers psychic health or a
lack thereof
Lisa and I cooked up some fairly
worrisome scenarios on TV one night we
watched a movie called the snake pit it
starred Olivia de Havilland as this
fairly nice if somewhat high-strung lady
who were over baroque brooches and
belted dresses when vacuuming her house
but who nevertheless had a twitchy mouth
early in the movie that poor shadowed
her hellacious capital B breakdown later
the film's title captures how the mental
ward got portrayed there was an icy
bathtub in which one maniac got dunked
under wet wet canvas finally poor miss
de Havilland got locked in a padded room
and belted into one of those long arms
straight jackets that forced you to hug
yourself all day and besides which
looked really hot all the while she was
hallucinating snakes crawling all over
that was the picture of mental ward life
for the full-blown nervous that Lisa and
I settled on it was all we had
I've just one more question and then
I'll open it up to everyone else I'm
interested in how the memoir is
different from fiction because in many
ways Mary you described your book as an
active memory in many ways the act of
remembering is an act of fiction making
we you know memory informs the mansion
ation and vice versa if not we would
have video cameras on our heads and we
would have undifferentiated experience
and you actually would have a
chronological book which would go on
tediously forever the way we remember
things the way we remember this weekend
remember the way we'll remember this
panel will be fashioned into almost
narrative like moments what is the
difference between Martin what is the
difference between memoirs like these
that which are all very different from
each other and a work of fiction
maybe there's no difference oh there's a
lot of difference fiction comes from the
Nabokov described as a throb he said the
first throb of the Lolita went through
me then he tells a rather unlikely tale
of of reading an article about how a
chief was trained to draw and all it
could draw was the bars of its cage and
eq's sort of kind of measures up to
Lolita but but that's the kind of
relationship between the throb and what
you end up with I mean the trouble is
with memoirs is it's all true the truth
is a drag basically you have to liven it
up with all these structural tricks
they're not the novel is comes from the
back of the mind and the memoir comes
from the front it's the treble of
memoirs but it's also the virtue of the
appeal of memoirs is that it's a true
story
yeah and it's more Universal for that
reason
I'd like to open it up to questions but
first want to thank our very very
special guest Martin Amos David Gary
Carr
a question there's one right yeah we got
a little um I'm interested in Dave and
Mary both to talk a little bit about
mechanics you talked about using
brackets the ellipses and dialogue you
know avoiding that I noticed in Cherry
you are writing as though you were
writing dialogue but without quotation
marks and also you just mentioned the
capital letters in your in your works
could you comment a little bit on how
you use that and what that means in your
work I think I think yeah you know I
think I'd rewrite for the 8,000th time
blood meridian you know the great Cormac
MacCarthy novel and and put always some
you know amazed me about you know
anybody who writes great dialing Frank I
think you use the same same thing right
where you don't use quotes I I think
you're forced then to distinguish
between the voices to such an extent
that so I just thought it was a you know
sort of set the bar higher if the reader
were going to be located in the
conversation that the voices had to be
very crisp and distinct also maybe an
implicit acknowledgement that you're
having to make up the dialogues a little
bit well I mean I think I got the
dialogue entirely I think when well
obviously yeah I mean you know I don't
remember all this stuff I have only been
able to [ __ ] myself that I do I mean
that's you know I think that goes
without saying that it's we constructive
dialogue but I think at this point in
literary history when history in general
when our notion of history objective
history has pretty much been tarnished
to say the least you know even before
Nixon I think it was going down them
down the long slide but no I mean I
think also by not having quotation marks
it it forces a reader more sort of into
the narrator's head I think as a device
that does that I think yeah when Mary
McCarthy published memories of the
Catholic girlhood back in the 50s you
know she had to go through and write
these long elaborate explanations to the
beginning of of every chapter correcting
and explaining that she was
reconstructing dialogue and I think she
had a New Yorker fact checker working
with her she had a gun to her head in
other words but yeah I mean I think it
isn't at this a at this stage in
literary history I think there's a tacit
agreement with a with a reader that
that's what's going on but I think not
using quotes specifically you're sort of
forced to go into the head of the
speaker or you know the narrator more
David use quotes is actually quite bring
it and we were talking about it earlier
it's almost as if you're you've written
it but I like plays inside of your book
yeah some of the some of the dialogue I
could get pretty accurately because um
it wasn't that far back you know tonight
talking and some of it's very easy it's
just hey hey hey hey
what what you know man that's very
accurate
to be able to do that I was taking notes
while we were talking and stuff it was
people hey dude write down hey oh yeah
but I had fun with the dialogue I I
found that the the few stories that I
ever attempted were 90% dialogue and and
so then putting that together that's
where there's there's a lot of extended
periods they're just that and I I had
fun with that and then but then I got
bored with that and then started having
people saying things that they couldn't
have possibly said either I sort of
liked both ends of it but the in-between
I'm not so good at like sentient
dialogue in actual sentence form
anyone's speaking more than three three
or four words at a time I think I get
clumsy so let's stick with the mono
syllabic at hey hey hey hey
and actually within this book I'm
working on now I find myself doing that
exact like exact same exchanges and I
have to like that's myself my favorite
thing that hey hey hey okay
anyway Harold Pinter made a career out
of it yeah anyone they didn't have hey
another question
Berger um I'm a retired high school
English teacher and right and I'm
recently getting into reading just for
fun could you guys recommend a book I
should read for fun
experience I'm joking
well I think what I'm thinking about
certain books that back in the 60s that
shocked the Charlotte Erica Young is a
fear of flying and JP Dunleavy's the
ginger man and I suppose you've read all
these Catcher in the Rye I like books
that that I like to back look at the
books that shocked the world of time and
they were generally banned in Ireland
but you won't have any won't have any
trouble but that I think I don't know
whether you're interested in fiction or
nonfiction but the writer I keep by my
bedside a lot these days is MFK Fisher
and the art of eating it's a trilogy
it's very it's a very rich trilogy
former New Yorker contributor Martin's
father wrote what I think is one of
funniest books in English which is a
book called lucky Jim and so if you're
looking for fun I think that's enough
when people in prints I know check into
mental institutions this is the book I
send I mostly know my another question I
feel
thank you I'm fascinated with the
selection of a title of a book and he'll
it evolves from the book itself and I
address this to Frank Angela's Ashes how
did you come upon that title and also
your very last word about Angela's Ashes
is tis did you pre-select that knowing
that your next volume would be titled
t's you never know what you're doing in
life I when I started out to write this
book at which I didn't know it I didn't
know if it was ever going to be
published I I was going to write the
whole story of my beginnings you know on
how are you know did this you know and
that and I'd go up to at the time my
mother died because that the
all-encompassing story but I I got to
like I had the idea of Angela's Ashes
and I want because it's a literature and
it's stuck in people's minds as I found
out later and I kept it even though it
has nothing to do with Angela's Ashes if
you want to read about Angela's Ashes
you have to look at the sex next book
tis which is still available now fine
bookstores but the second book the
second book in when the second book my
mother died and we cremate her and took
her ashes to Ireland and I just did I
just kept that title because I didn't
want to let go it be simply because I
didn't know if I could ever finish the
second book and then tis the last words
of Angela's Ashes became the title of
the second and I got a lot into a lot of
trouble over that that ending is one
chapter one Ward a one more chapter
chapter 19 and I got letters from people
saying there were missing pages and they
wanted their money back
Dave your title is unusual
a staggering a heartbreaking work of
staggering genius tell us about the
evolution of that title it was well
growing up to get any attention in our
house you had to burst through the door
and say that I'm the greatest
you know geometry student that ever
lived and my dad would come home and say
he was the greatest lawyer he had never
lost a case and everybody kneel at his
feet and we would and that was just sort
of you had to celebrate yourself every
day and demand attention because my
parents really didn't give a [ __ ] they
didn't lead other than look at her
grades or anything they just expected of
us certain things and so it just came
from that and then it made me laugh and
and I thought it would be it would save
reviewers a lot of time oh no no not
that way
I just meant they could just say either
they would they would they could just
say it's not you know that would be the
review and uh so I thought it was it was
just inviting trouble trouble yeah it
was just something that I've been doing
since I was little is is that I thought
the whole thing was an act of
self-destruction and that was the cap on
it all yeah Martin how did you come by
your title experience it's it's sort of
um it evolved with the book and I didn't
really like it as a title but I thought
I can't call it anything else and I
think there are two kinds of titles
there's um you know the the first kind
is it sucked if someone gives you a
puppy out of the blue then you've got to
think of a name for it and sometimes you
to finish a book without really happy
you see then you go think of a name for
the title you prefers is the one that
grows with the book and is kind of
involved in every page of the book and
it's more like naming a child which
isn't as arbitrary as we sometimes think
I think you know the way the child
behaves in the womb shapes what you call
it in a curious way Wiggly little no
another question I think there's one
right right back here yeah you don't
have to wait for there either
belt it out first no more when you talk
coming on who you're talking this left
the other left that's left yeah we know
I said everybody on the website how's
that in other words everyone in New York
and work on a memoir oh can you talk a
bit about how you raise the bar because
with the exception of mr. Amos who was
writing a bit as a celebrity all of you
were everyday people and how do you go
about making experiences everyday
experiences be something more
and everyday experiences I've had a lot
of people ask me how you remember things
in order to write a memoir a my only
piece of advice about writing them where
is this if you can't remember things
maybe you shouldn't write a memoir well
my only piece of advice was like how do
you remember stuff and I'm like I don't
remember anything but I'm trying to
write this memoir I'm like why
not nothing is significant until you
make it significant that that's that's
why you dinner your head last night with
somebody and it just sits there and you
probably don't remember what you had or
so but if you if you want you can reach
back and you can give it all kinds of
meaning the conversation that there was
a movie out a few years ago called my
dinner with Andre I think and more than
a few years ago I don't know what it is
what people want to see and I said I
watched it and listen to it and so on
what the hell was that all about and
that's what you say about life in
general what the hell was that all about
and that and then you said what this is
what it was about this is what it means
to me and then you gonna write your
memoir and then make it into a movie I
bet you found that helpful don't cancel
your subscription to The New York
another question over here on the side
treble and the semicolon is and in terms
of shaping piece whether it's a fiction
or
you think the same you think in each
case reduces her strength you have to
have nothing no sort of
the question is them how much does
fiction really keep you out of trouble
as opposed to nonfiction and perhaps
related to the question about the title
do you know do you know the ending once
you've begun I know the ending of a
novel you don't you don't need not to
know much about a novel to get going
just a situation and the novel money for
instance was based on one idea which was
there's this fat guy in New York trying
to make a film that's all I had but I
didn't know I knew something about the
beginning I knew something about the
ending I knew something about the middle
it's a journey without maps but with a
destination and did you know how
experience was gonna end uh yeah a
fairly good idea and another question
I am the back here the novelists Maureen
feely American and here in the fact
in terms of the the question is are
these not merely reenactments of The
Oprah Show which puts me in mind of a
question that I was diet that I was
dying to put everybody thank you which
is from BS Pritchett who was writing
before Oprah had her television show who
wrote that the autobiographer has been
said to resemble a stripper and the
suspense is wondering just how much he
or she will reveal no the I don't want
to scare them all out i I think that
memorize the exact opposite of that
because the the nature of those shows is
the nature of television and video and
movies is reductive it's a reductive
form it reduces things to the soundbite
this moment and the the great thing
about a memoir is that you're given
death and I think the reason people have
been so passionate about reading them
and had bought these books and other
other memoirs in this particular moment
in literary history is we're kind of
lonely and isolated and all trying to
figure out how we're going to continue
to eat Thanksgiving dinner with the
people work in - and memoirs I think go
in-depth into those conflicts in a way
that Jenny Jones and Oprah do not
that's a reductive it's like a soundbite
of what happens thank you must have been
asked this question well what mary was
talking I was listening of course by
that
I was also thinking about that great
gush of our books that Henry Miller let
loose in the world and then his friend
wasn't I know yes sir yes
and they ass and then well I read but I
read both of them I found it very hard
to get so nice then because she got very
delicate and very subtle like and my did
cure insomnia but what was that question
we like Oprah no no I don't think so I
know it's definitely not I don't think
so I think you could I think you could I
think about the meetings out there or
gonna radio books but I've we discussed
at the very beginning of this discussion
talk about when you you're not gonna
settle any scores you're not gonna get
even you you don't want you really don't
want to be sensational you're not
interested in being sensational it you
you you keep the details of sexual
exploits to a minimum if that's what you
want to do unless you're a stud or
something like that you want to show
your prowess but I think I think that's
been done so much by Henry Miller and
other paper that people will go home
again and that's not you have to you
have to you it's the use of the language
what you do with the language that that
holds people attention because everybody
has read everything as far as intimate
details are concerned and you have it's
not that you want to help them in any
way but you want to tell your story
because each story I used to tell my
students in high school there's no such
thing as a boring person I've had
occasion to regret that statement
but I think what you want to do mainly
is is tell your story because the very
fact the very act of sitting at a desk
betrays an enormous ego Oh my story well
also you go there with all humility
because and I went there with all
humility I thought I had a story to tell
but I didn't think it would be as as
widely read as it was so I'm surprised
I'm the constant state of surprise and
it has nothing to do with television or
media or anything else I think if I can
venture an opinion in this as well I was
I looked at an article that James Atlas
had written five years ago about the
Renaissance of the memoir and if
anything this is where the New York
Times Magazine and I thought if anything
was gonna kill the memoir it would be
the New York Times and it was
interesting looking at his piece because
he was citing a lot of memos which have
all disappeared and I think in the same
way that there was a big VOC and travel
writing in Britain in the 80s and
everybody seemed to be writing travel
books the truth is that almost all these
books are occasion for the latest
occasions of the good book survive and
the writers write original books and
what we have here four people have
written very very different books
structurally different books different
books is narrative that they couldn't be
more different and if he called the same
thing and with that pretentious
observation I want to thank you for
coming
and I want to thank actually the authors
of these very very exceptional books The
New Yorker festival is a really a
celebration of the magazine's writers
and its readers today we have four
writers who have contributed to the
magazine and the real secret of the real
mission of this one is to get you to get
them dry for us more
thank you